selphie kid orion mckenna gets a major  surprise on Ellen Justin  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  we all saw the selfie go down at the  Super Bowl Justin Timberlake and 13-year  old Ryan McKenna met for a split second  to snap this pic I've gotten so much  like stuff on social media and stuff  it's crazy  my phone's blown up but they didn't get  to actually meet until now there's  someone on the phone that wants to say  hi to you right now yeah Justin  [Applause]  it's okay so it was just a phone call  but there is more Justin invited Ryan to  his tour stop in Boston I really want to  meet you properly  [Applause]  Brian I look forward to meeting you and  our second selfie together  yeah  [Music]